Hey, David, what is the best way to take advantage
of the Corona virus quarantine in terms of
personal development and how to use free time?
So I dealt with this a little bit on the Monday
bonus show.
I've been trying to get back to number one.
First of all, making sure that I don't get
out of, you know, exercise routines.
And on nice days, I can run outside and bike.
I'm working out inside of my place and trying
to keep that even without the gym as a place
that I normally would regularly go to.
I think that's important.
I've been reading a lot and trying to get
through a lot of books that normally would
take me longer to read.
I have more time on weekends.
I'm just sitting at home, so I'm just reading
books.
I pulled out my painting supplies again, as
many of you remember from the New York City
days of the show.
I used to do a little very, very bad amateur
painting.
I'm back doing that a little bit more.
I'm trying to do projects around the house.
I've been watching a lot of courses on YouTube.
Great philosophy, course of Rogue, a sort
of a refresher on mechanical physics, which
brought me back to my high school days.
Anything that you believe, here's the way
I would sort of think about it.
Consider this almost like a hibernation period
where instead of hibernating to reduce food
consumption, the way that bears would do during
the winter, your heart hibernating and trying
to improve yourself so that when we come out
of this thing someday, we don't know exactly
when you will come out a better, more prepared
person for getting back to normal life.
And, you know, existing more vitally in society.
And, you know, all of that's.
I.
Listen, we're all dealing with the same thing.
That's the sort of best case scenario that
I can imagine.
And that's what I'm trying to do.
I will admit.
I have been doing a little bit of videogaming,
former producer Lewis recommended some game
to me.
I forget then it's some puzzle game that was
on.
It was available on steam that he's been playing.
I forget the name of it, but it's really,
really good.
I've been playing that a little bit.
I've been playing probably more online chess
than I normally do, but I think it's important
to mix things.
I've been taking scheduled breaks from the
Corona virus news, as I did last Friday, Saturday
and most of Sunday.
So I think it's about balance.
Hanging out digitally and reconnecting with
friends is something that I've been doing.
And it's everybody is experiencing this this
feeling to some degree, unless you're not
doing anything.
I know that in some states people are still
partying on beaches and going to concerts
and that sort of thing.
But for those of us who are taking this seriously,
I get it.
I'm here with you.
We're doing a lot of livestreams to try to
give people opportunities to, you know, be
in touch with us and participate.
But those are some of my things try to come
out of this a more informed, more literate,
healthier person, if possible.
And of course, meanwhile, trying to avoid
the virus itself.
We've got a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Get access instantly by becoming a member
or a patron at joint Packman dot com or Patriarca
slash David Pakman.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dicom.